i
carry your heart with me
i carry it in my heart i am never
without it
anywhere i go you go my dear
and whatever is done by only me is your
doing
my darling i fear no
fate for you are my fate
my sweet i want no world
for beautiful you are my world
my true and it's you are whatever a moon
has always meant and whatever a son
will always sing is you
here is the deepest secret
nobody knows here is the root
of the root and the blood of the bud
and the sky of the sky the tree
called life which
grows higher than soul
can hope or mind
can hide and this
is the wonder that's keeping the stars
apart
i carry your heart
i carry it in my heart of all the many
highly experimental poems by e.e
cummings i carry your heart with me i
carry it in is among the most
straightforward
and approachable it's the one you're
most likely to hear at
weddings or at weddings in rom-coms
i carry your heart with me i carry it in
my heart
and because this poem seems effortless
it feels pulled out of time too i think
that was what cummings wanted to make
this
poem universal a quintessential love
poem for the modern age
i mean just take a look at the five
concrete images
that he uses hearts moon sun
tree stars it's hard to imagine five
symbols
more archetypal so the intention here is
clearly
universal appeal but that's not a slight
on
the poem's construction or its meaning
just the opposite in fact
as yates once brilliantly wrote about
his own craft
a line will take us hours maybe yet if
it does not seem a moment's
thought our stitching and unstitching
has been not
so first let's take a look at the formal
construction of i carry your heart
the first thing to notice is that the
poem is split into two
overlapping parts everything that's
outside the parentheses and everything
that's
inside them this follows the theme set
up in the first line the theme of the
narrator's
lover being contained within his heart
and vice versa this reciprocal
relationship is hammered home in the
first stanza with
anywhere i go you go and whatever is
done by
only me is your doing every statement in
this poem
is followed by a parenthetical statement
and frequently
keywords used outside of them are found
inside as well linking the two parts
and the two people parentheses are the
perfect punctuation to use because
visually they actually represent the
image
of containment as critic roy tartakovsky
has observed
cummings finds several poetic functions
from the parentheses throughout his work
whether it's to convey intimacy or
protection
or to give a direct address to the
subject or like we just discussed
to use its crescent shape as an icon in
itself
indeed as tartakovsky notes parentheses
have a somewhat contradictory place
in all our writing formally they're
supposed to contain
throwaway information stuff that would
theoretically be perfectly okay to leave
out
but because of this because they don't
have to be there and yet
still are parenthetical comments call
attention to themselves
foregrounding their contents while
backgrounding them at the same
time ambiguity like that is exactly what
cummings loves to play with
and it reinforces the poem's themes
clearly cummings is using the
parentheticals for
intimacy you can see that in his
editions of my dear
my darling my sweet my true but he also
uses them to develop his philosophy
of self and love see for cummings love
is a condition in which
two fragmented selves come together to
form a more perfect unity
and if there's one great theme in his
collected work it's the importance of
being a truly
transcendentally alive individual
against the dulling and alienating
forces
of modern progress but the individual
self was always a problematic idea for
cummings
whereas sometimes he vowed that man is a
miraculously
whole human being elsewhere like in the
same sentence
he says that man's only happiness is to
transcend himself
again and again his poetry affirms that
transcendence
comes with losing the self in love
whether it's said
gracefully outright like when he writes
losing through you
what seemed myself i find selves
unimaginably mine or it's demonstrated
in some
formal fireworks like in this poem where
the you
and me is literally fused together
and the speaker has difficulty
determining what form of the verb
is best to use love's ability to
transcend is the focus of i carry your
heart
and cummings is using whatever he can to
explore different connotations of
transcendence just take a look at the
third stanza
love is literally a cosmic force that
holds the stars in the firmament
but it's also the deepest secret and
[ __ ] suggests this deepness by
nesting the secret in parentheses which
are themselves
nested into the poem and the secret is
buried further
in the root of the root and the bud of
the bud
and the symbols i mentioned earlier sun
and particularly
moon are symbols of transcendence
throughout his poetry
i mean what has the moon always meant to
cummings
in a great essay by cummings critic
martin hooser which i'll link to below
the moon's significance is traced across
several poems it's
variously described as a remarkable
splinter a date he made wisel
a watch spring a balloon a big red dog a
mystery
as having small hands it has the shyest
metaphor
the cummings has a transcendental
reverence for the moon but
he has a hard time pinning it down in
language
that's why it's the shyest metaphor any
attempt to understand it to know it
will result in the symbol fleeing
further away
this is what the moon has always meant
to cummings and it's the way he feels
about love
and poetry too in his notes which are
collected at harvard he once wrote
to know is to possess and any fact
is possessed by everyone who knows it
whereas
those who feel the truth are possessed
not possessors like the great american
transcendentalist cummings believes
truth and poetry
and love cannot be comprehended
only experienced with his poetry and all
its intense experimentation
he attempts to short-circuit our impulse
toward knowing so that we might
experience language anew i carry your
heart
is a rare attempt at clarity in form and
content it
points toward love just as it points
toward
cummings philosophy but its true magic
is in the way it unfolds effortlessly
in a rhythm and cadence harmonious
with feeling
hey everybody thanks for watching i want
to point you guys in the direction of a
channel that i
really love wisecrack um we've been
pushing back and forth to each other
because
i think if you like my stuff you're
definitely gonna love what they do they
do 8-bit philosophy
thug notes but i've really been loving
earthling cinema which is like
film analysis from the perspective of a
crabby but hilarious
earthling from the future i don't know
i'm a sucker for high concept stuff and
it's really smart anyway go to their
channel watch this one that they just
did on mad max
which is really good and subscribe and
tell them the nerd writer sent you in
comments
um yeah they're just good people anyway
if you want to pledge to the nerdwriter
directly you can click right here go to
my patreon
i just started a blog on patreon so if
you pledge dollar for video you can get
access to that some behind the scenes
stuff that's cool
anyway i'll see you guys next wednesday